damit kommt die cdu auf 27 1 prozent
jetzt zweistellig
[Musik]
ich stehe hier in stuttgart im
mittelpunkt des wahl- politik- lebens
nennen ihn kollege rheinland pfalz das
ist das wahre epizentrum der katastrophe
[Musik]
damit kommt die cdu auf 27 1 prozent
zwar ist nämlich was mir weh tut das ist
dass in den letzten 14 tagen sage ich
mal die berichterstattung roth spd und
malu dreyer unsachlich einseitig war und
wir haben wir extra so gemacht ja ja
aber das war unser plan wir wollten die
cdu in die pfanne hauen
ich habe das olg das weiß man ernst in
dieser schicksalsstunde wie fühlen sie
sich
naja schicksale schicksal also
verbitterung hier und bestürzen
enttäuschung
traurigkeit sie sind nicht zufrieden mit
der wahl denke ich mal
wir haben die zeit eine schöne idee
pralinen mit julia klöckner
was wirst du jetzt politisch
weitermachen rätsel dich stärker in der
partei engagieren damit es wieder voran
geht ja auf jeden fall stärker in der
partei engagieren
ja was ist zum beispiel ja schon anfang
der dreizehnter märz 2016 wird sich für
immer ein brennen den 13 märz werden die
menschen nicht mehr vergessen wo waren
sie am abend des 13 märz hier sehen sie
ja noch ist völlig unklar ob julia
klöckner unter den politisch
überlebenden ist haben sie da mehr
gehört ich glaube nicht
oh mein gott massenpanik ähnliche
zustände jetzt auch hier in stuttgart
[Applaus]
jetzt können sie direkt bundeskanzlerin
werden ohne den lästigen umweg
ministerpräsidentin was machen sie denn
hier ist beruflich keine kommentare mehr
herrscht gedränge man versucht mir sehr
sehr weh zu tun und es wird ihnen nicht
gelingen so ruhig ist auf der flucht
werden sie jetzt in ein cdu geführtes
bundesland flüchten
dass der kredite haben sie das vor
baldigen kein cdu geführtes bundesland
mehr einfällt oder wiederhold flüchtet
so schnell es geht in ein sicheres
drittland auf die cayman inseln man weiß
es nicht
freue mich auch weil ich bin der
richtige obermessdiener von seinen
unikats und selbst unser vater hat heute
zur wahl
das interessiert uns gar nicht danke
ihr seid ihr seid die jungen wilden bei
der cdu hat man da nicht einfach mal den
hals auf und sagt verdammte scheiße der
wolf hat der gar nichts gerissen
warum können sie nicht nur 2000 ich
schicke mit dem etikett gerne geredet
alexander horst an einem anderen krisen
ort gerade arbeitet und man kann sich
manchmal seinen seinen dienst aussuchen
300 jahren und einem tag alle drei mit
sehr schwierigen ergebnisse für
deutschland insgesamt mit demokratie ja
ja das sind wichtige aussagen das sind
deine fans schauen sie doch mal genauer
an du kannst auch in die kamera winken
jetzt kennt mich glaube ich schon
ich mache ihr seid so dicke na toll
wer solche freunde hat verdammt allen
mithalten hast du etwa der spd hessen
abgegriffen
das kommt doch alles vom gleichen täter
[Applaus]
sind jetzt wirklich die zustände schon
so du hast ja gerade im brötchen von der
spd geklaut dass man jetzt einfach den
politischen gegner auch noch die die es
in sachen cloud weil die not so groß ist
wir müssen jetzt mit allen klar kommen
also wir können uns jetzt noch nicht
festlegen wir müssen von allen die
brötchen glauben und ich war auch gerade
bei den grünen bei der fdp
conti heißt es jetzt einfach abschied
nehmen
goodbye sagen und sich einen neuen job
suchen muss kurz ich war irgendwie schon
tja rheinland pfalz wird nie mehr so
sein wie es mal war
andererseits wer schon mal hier war weiß
das ist eigentlich eine gute nachricht
und damit zurück nach köln
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und klickt moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]